After a mass shooting or a terrorist attack, people want to know how did this happen or why didn't we see it coming? Friends and family members of the perpetrator rarely seem to have clear answers. Can psychological science step in and put together the pieces of this unsolved puzzle? We speak with a psychologist about fear and violence and why mental health experts need to be on the front lines of violence prevention efforts. But maybe not in the way you think. I'm Audrey Hamilton and this is Speaking of Psychology. Frank Farley is the Laura H. Carnell professor of psychological studies and education at Temple University and an internationally recognized authority on psychology and human behavior.
在大规模枪击事件或恐怖袭击发生后，人们想知道这是怎么发生的，或者为什么我们没有预见到它？肇事者的朋友和家人似乎很少有明确的答案。心理科学能否介入并拼凑出这个未解之谜的碎片？我们采访了一位心理学家，探讨恐惧与暴力，以及为什么心理健康专家需要站在暴力预防工作的第一线。但可能不是你想象的那种方式。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。弗兰克·法利是天普大学劳拉·H·卡内尔心理学与教育学教授，也是国际公认的心理学和人类行为权威。
He has extensively researched and published on extreme behavior, specifically risk-taking, as well as crime and violence. A former president of the American Psychological Association, Dr. Farley, is experienced in translating psychological science for the media. Welcome, Dr. Farley. Happy to be here. A lot of psychologists have been on the news lately. including you, talking about the psychology of mass shooters and terrorists.
他在极端行为，特别是冒险行为，以及犯罪和暴力方面进行了广泛的研究并发表了著作。作为美国心理学会的前主席，法利博士在向媒体转化心理科学方面经验丰富。欢迎您，法利博士。很高兴来到这里。最近有很多心理学家出现在新闻中，包括您，讨论大规模枪击者和恐怖分子的心理。
Do you think psychologists have something valuable to contribute to these stories? If so, you know, tell us what you think that is. Well, one of the key things in psychology is understanding individual behavior. We're also good at large group behavior and social behavior, etc. But historically, one of our greatest strengths was understanding the individual. And so things like motive and motivation, influences in the, the individuals' upbringing, et cetera, can all come into play. One of the problems is that we don't get to study many mass shooters.
您认为心理学家对这些故事有什么宝贵的贡献吗？如果是的话，请告诉我们您认为那是什么。嗯，心理学的关键之一是理解个体行为。我们也擅长大型群体行为和社会行为等。但从历史上看，我们最大的优势之一是理解个体。因此，动机、个人成长经历中的影响等因素都可以发挥作用。问题之一是我们无法研究很多大规模枪击者。
Why? Because they're dead. So we don't get to really study a whole lot of them in depth. We know quite a bit, but there's also a lot of speculation. But the way we work is typically we take a look at sort of how we understand normal behavior. And then can we understand anything about these deviations? from normal. And so that requires that we know a lot about normal behavior, which is itself difficult. In fact, often more difficult than the abnormal behavior, because the abnormal behavior is so unusual and so stark and stands out so much from everything else. It's often easier
为什么？因为他们死了。所以我们无法真正深入研究他们中的大多数。我们知道得不少，但也有很多猜测。但我们的工作方式通常是观察我们如何理解正常行为。然后我们能否理解这些对正常的偏离？这需要我们对正常行为有深入了解，而这本身就很困难。事实上，这通常比异常行为更难，因为异常行为非常罕见、非常鲜明，与其他一切截然不同。它通常更容易
to study it because it's so extreme, whereas everyday normal behavior is sometimes hard to get your arms around, you know? It's too great. But of all the disciplines, there's no discipline in the world that has more to offer in understanding terrorists, mass shooters, et cetera. We're a long way from, you know, predictive power. And I think that's what's so unsettling for a lot of people these days. Indeed. So when we have a terrorist incident, what typically happens is we go digging into everything,
研究，因为它太极端了，而日常的正常行为有时很难把握，你知道吗？它太宏大了。但在所有学科中，世界上没有哪个学科比我们更能为理解恐怖分子、大规模枪击者等提供帮助。我们离预测能力还很远。我认为这正是当今许多人感到不安的原因。确实。所以当我们发生恐怖事件时，通常发生的情况是我们会深入挖掘一切，
the whole autobiography of this person. who they knew, who they talked to. We searched their computers. You know, what websites were they hanging out on? Were they in touch with ISIS or some other group of relevance? What about family? So we talk to neighbors, you know. And so we hope to find individual qualities that will help us in the next instance,
这个人的整个人生传记。他们认识谁，和谁交谈过。我们搜索他们的电脑。你知道，他们常去哪些网站？他们是否与ISIS或其他相关组织有联系？家人呢？所以我们和邻居交谈，你知道。我们希望找到有助于下一次事件的个人特质，
because this mass murderer or this terrorist is probably dead. but can we learn something that might help us next time round? And that's typically the M.O. You know, of psychologists' contributions. We sometimes do what some people call a post-mortem, you know, a psychological post-mortem, and that's kind of what I'm talking about here. If we do find things, that can then be fed into the work of the profiler, the FBI profilers, all the other profilers, giving them some clues,
因为这个大规模杀人犯或恐怖分子可能已经死了。但我们能学到一些可能在下次有所帮助的东西吗？这通常是心理学家贡献的运作方式。我们有时会做一些人所说的尸检，你知道，心理尸检，这就是我在这里所说的。如果我们确实发现了某些东西，那么这些信息可以被输入到侧写师、FBI侧写师以及所有其他侧写师的工作中，给他们提供一些线索，
that they might look for. One problem there is that what happens if you come up with a pretty good profile of a mass murderer? And by the way, we don't have one yet. But what if we did? One issue there is, what are you going to do about it? So let's say that there's some guy, and by the way, most mass murderers are males between 20 and 40, what do you do about it? Let's say you know of somebody who meets those criteria.
他们可能会去寻找。这里的一个问题是，如果你得出了一个关于大规模杀人犯的相当不错的侧写会怎样？顺便说一句，我们还没有一个。但如果我们有呢？这里的一个问题是，你打算怎么处理它？假设有个人，顺便说一句，大多数大规模杀人犯是20到40岁的男性，你打算怎么处理？假设你知道某个人符合这些标准。
Now, there might be thousands of people who meet those criteria, but somehow or other, one comes into the purview of the police, and they look and say, boy, this guy, he meets all of the criteria that we know of so far. What are you going to do about it? Are you going to arrest him before the crime is committed? You can't do that. That's called preventive detention, you know. You can't arrest a person before they've committed a crime.
现在，可能有成千上万的人符合这些标准，但不知何故，一个人进入了警方的视野，他们查看后说，天哪，这家伙符合我们目前所知的所有标准。你打算怎么处理？你打算在犯罪发生前逮捕他吗？你不能那样做。这叫预防性拘留，你知道。你不能在一个人犯罪前逮捕他。
they've got to commit the crime, presumably. So in the years ahead, as we get better and better at it, we're going to run right into this issue. If we have some good predictive power vis-a-vis crimes, then we come into a huge issue, what do we do about that? Right now, everything's ex post facto. It's looking back, and it's interesting and often helpful. But one day from now, in the future,
他们必须犯罪，大概是这样。所以在未来的几年里，随着我们越来越擅长这一点，我们将直接遇到这个问题。如果我们对犯罪有很好的预测能力，那么我们就会面临一个巨大的问题，我们该怎么办？现在，一切都是事后诸葛亮。这是回顾过去，这很有趣，通常也有帮助。但从现在起的一天，在未来，
we're going to have to decide, once we've got a lot of really valuable and valid information, what does society do about it? What about the idea, and I think a lot about what you're talking about is, you know, the biography of the shooter, who did they know, what did they do before they committed this act? You know, how can we put together all the clues that led to this event? You know, it's one of the things that I know has been sort of a topic of controversies, the idea of media contagion and its role in... mass shootings. Media contagion, this is the idea that mass shooters want the sort of media
我们将不得不决定，一旦我们有了大量真正有价值和有效的信息，社会该怎么办？关于这个想法，我想了很多你谈到的，你知道，枪手的传记，他们认识谁，他们在实施这种行为之前做了什么？你知道，我们如何拼凑出导致这一事件的所有线索？你知道，我知道这一直是一个争议话题，即媒体传染及其在...大规模枪击事件中的作用。媒体传染，这是一个想法，即大规模枪击者想要那种媒体
tension other perpetrators get after these attacks. Do you think it exists and how should the media deal with it? I look at all these things as caused by a recipe with several ingredients. There's almost none of this behavior that can be said to be due to one thing. And that's very typical of psychology. And so most of human behavior is cause, the source of it is, the source of it is, a recipe with several ingredients. So one terrorist or one mass shooter might have one set of ingredients, and some of those ingredients might be found in another mass shooter, but not all the same ingredients.
其他肇事者在这些袭击后得到的关注。你认为它存在吗？媒体应该如何处理它？我看待所有这些事情都是由几种成分组成的配方。几乎没有这种行为可以说是由一件事引起的。这在心理学中非常典型。所以大多数人类行为的原因，它的来源，是一个有几种成分的配方。所以一个恐怖分子或一个大规模枪击者可能有一组成分，其中一些成分可能在另一个大规模枪击者身上找到，但并非所有成分都相同。
So there might be some overlapping ingredients, and then some ones that don't overlap. I think that, yes, some of these perps are motivated by fame. We don't have a number. We really don't. We have to be honest. We don't have a number. But I think definitely that some of them do it for the fame, for the attention.
所以可能有一些重叠的成分，然后是一些不重叠的。我认为，是的，其中一些肇事者是出于名声的动机。我们没有具体数字。我们真的没有。我们必须诚实。我们没有数字。但我认为肯定有些人是为了名声，为了关注而这样做。
And, you know, lots of people go through life, never getting any attention at all. People aren't paying attention to them in any way. And they feel they're a nobody, they're in nothing. And then they see this event happen, you know, it's some heinous event. And another person, sort of like them, they think, suddenly is being talked about all over the world. And that has a twisted appeal, I think, for some people. I would probably call them a thrill seeker in many respects. It's a thrill, it's excitement. I've done a lot of work on what I call the type T personality, the thrill seeker. I would speculate that many of these
而且，你知道，很多人一生都没有得到任何关注。人们根本没有以任何方式关注他们。他们觉得他们是个无名小卒，什么都不是。然后他们看到这个事件发生，你知道，这是一个令人发指的事件。而另一个像他们一样的人，他们认为，突然间全世界都在谈论他。我认为这对某些人来说有一种扭曲的吸引力。我可能会在许多方面称他们为寻求刺激者。这是一种刺激，这是一种兴奋。我在我所说的T型人格，即寻求刺激者方面做了很多工作。我会推测其中许多
people are in fact T-types, and it's exciting. Probably the most extreme act a person can do. take the life, the precious life of another individual. And it's that act that we in psychology have to understand. And we're not there yet. I think some people feel like these violent acts and terrorist acts are an epidemic. Are more people afraid? Should they be? Would you consider what's happening recently an epidemic of violence? I don't. I feel that it's very important to keep perspective on this whole problem. Know your probabilities. So you are more likely to die from a drunk out on the highway than you are to be died due to a terrorist. In fact, the number of people killed through terrorist acts in America since 9-11 is minuscule. It's a very small number.
人实际上是T型人格，这很令人兴奋。这可能是一个人能做的最极端的行为。夺走另一个人的生命，宝贵的生命。而正是这种行为，我们心理学必须去理解。我们还没有做到。我认为有些人觉得这些暴力行为和恐怖行为是一种流行病。更多的人感到害怕吗？他们应该吗？你会认为最近发生的事情是暴力流行病吗？我不这么认为。我觉得保持对这个问题的整体看法非常重要。了解你的概率。所以你死于高速公路上的醉酒司机的可能性比死于恐怖分子之手的可能性更大。事实上，自911以来，美国因恐怖行为而丧生的人数微乎其微。这是一个非常小的数字。
They're all important, of course, and a tragedy. But compared to the other things that can happen to you, it's minor at best. And so... So it does worry me that people begin saying, oh my God, we've got an epidemic of terrorism. We don't. And that's simply a fact. And a very important lesson out of the world of psychology is for individuals, it's very important to keep perspective. There's something that's more important than the events that happen, and that is your
当然，他们都很重要，都是悲剧。但与其他可能发生在你身上的事情相比，它充其量是次要的。所以...所以人们开始说，天哪，我们有恐怖主义流行病，这确实让我担心。我们没有。这只是一个事实。心理学世界中一个非常重要的教训是，对于个人来说，保持视角非常重要。有些事情比发生的事件更重要，那就是你
interpretation of those events. In psychotherapy, that's a key concept. You want to get people to reframe or reinterpret that event. And the event, you don't want to catastrophize it. The same for a nation. And we don't want to catastrophize over a very small number of isolated terrorist events. FDR, Franklin D. Roosevelt said it better than anybody. The only thing we have to fear is fear itself.
对这些事件的解读。在心理治疗中，这是一个关键概念。你想让人们重构或重新解读那个事件。而那个事件，你不想把它灾难化。对于一个国家来说也是如此。我们不想对极少数孤立的恐怖事件进行灾难化。富兰克林·D·罗斯福说得比任何人都好。我们唯一要恐惧的就是恐惧本身。
We have to watch out for what I call tertiary terror. I believe that there's a way of looking at terrorism is there's what I call primary terror. You are there when it happens. You're in the nightclub in Orlando when the shooter comes in and starts killing people. That's primary terror. Secondary terror is when it gets reported by the media, which it does and it has to. It's got to be reported so the world knows. So the media then reports it.
我们必须警惕我所说的三级恐怖。我相信有一种看待恐怖主义的方式，就是我所说的初级恐怖。当它发生时你在现场。你在奥兰多的夜总会里，枪手进来开始杀人。那是初级恐怖。二级恐怖是当它被媒体报道时，确实如此，也必须如此。它必须被报道，这样世界才知道。所以媒体随后报道它。
That's secondary terror. tertiary terror, or the third phase of terror, is where we go on and on and talk about it and talk about it, and the whole nation starts to become afraid. That's exactly what the terrorists want to do. They are really in the business of what I call tertiary terror. They want to paralyze a nation with fear. And so, to your question, are more people afraid? I worry that they are, but it's not an epidemic.
那是二级恐怖。三级恐怖，或恐怖的第三阶段，是我们不断地谈论它，谈论它，整个国家开始变得恐惧。这正是恐怖分子想要做的。他们实际上是在从事我所说的三级恐怖。他们想用恐惧使一个国家瘫痪。所以，回到你的问题，更多的人感到害怕了吗？我担心他们是，但这并不是流行病。
a healthy nation has to retain appropriate balance and perspective on the events of that society. So even though we may not be facing an epidemic, you say, so some people feel like it's time to find ways to reduce violence in this country, maybe not terrorism necessarily or mass shootings, but other types of violence. You know, some people focus on gun control. Others say we need to put up walls, you know, to keep immigrants out of the country. How much of this debate is focused on emotion and gut feeling, rather than actual reason or psychological evidence?
一个健康的国家必须对该社会的事件保持适当的平衡和视角。所以即使我们可能没有面临流行病，你说，所以有些人觉得是时候找到减少这个国家暴力的方法了，也许不一定是恐怖主义或大规模枪击，而是其他类型的暴力。你知道，有些人关注枪支管制。其他人说我们需要筑墙，你知道，把移民挡在国门之外。这场辩论中有多少是基于情感和直觉，而不是实际的理性或心理学证据？
Well, a lot of it is emotion. As you know, the U.S. Congress will not allow U.S. federal dollars to be spent on research into gun control. By legislation, researchers are prevented from doing that kind of research if they want funds from the government. Now, you might be able to get funds from somewhere else, but it's a strong restriction. So we know less than vastly less than we should. about guns and gun violence and gun control.
嗯，很多是情感。如你所知，美国国会将不允许美国联邦资金用于枪支管制研究。根据法律，如果研究人员想要政府资金，他们被禁止进行那种研究。现在，你也许能从其他地方获得资金，但这是一种强有力的限制。所以我们知道的远比我们应该知道的要少得多。关于枪支、枪支暴力和枪支管制。
The main mechanism in violence in America is the gun. I remember in the wake of Sandy Hook, which had to be one of the most heinous of recent murders. Now, that's not a terrorist incident, but 26 children, I think it was, roughly 27, were slaughtered in an elementary school. That's as bad as it gets. In the aftermath of that, many of us who work in this area and think in this area felt, you know, people have got to wake up and do something about guns.
美国暴力的主要机制是枪支。我记得在桑迪胡克事件之后，那一定是最近最令人发指的谋杀案之一。现在，那不是恐怖事件，但我想大约有26名儿童，大约27名，在一所小学被屠杀。那是再糟糕不过了。在那之后，我们许多在这个领域工作和思考的人觉得，你知道，人们必须醒悟并对枪支做点什么。
It didn't happen. And my own guess is we need to tilt in other directions like education, deal with the person who's holding the gun in particular, so that they won't commit the crime. And that's where psychology is strong. Child psychology, school psychology. schools are so important in this whole debate. Some of the newer ideas like bullying interventions, and that's been around for a while. Forgiveness education.
它没有发生。我自己的猜测是，我们需要向其他方向倾斜，比如教育，特别处理那个拿着枪的人，这样他们就不会犯罪。而这正是心理学的强项。儿童心理学，学校心理学。学校在这个整个辩论中非常重要。一些较新的想法，比如欺凌干预，这已经存在一段时间了。宽恕教育。
I think that's a really important frontier. Forgiveness education. Bob Enright out at University of Wisconsin and Madison has developed forgiveness education. And it's being adopted in a lot of war zone places. Palestine. Liberia, the president of Liberia, a woman president, has adopted forgiveness education throughout the whole country in public schooling. So that's something we can try. We need as many new ideas as possible because the old ones don't seem to be working. And violence has drifted down a little
我认为这是一个非常重要的前沿。宽恕教育。威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校的鲍勃·恩赖特开发了宽恕教育。它正在许多战区被采用。巴勒斯坦。利比里亚，利比里亚总统，一位女总统，在全国的公立学校中采用了宽恕教育。所以这是我们可以尝试的事情。我们需要尽可能多的新想法，因为旧的想法似乎不起作用。而暴力已经下降了一点
bit over recent years, but not much. And I'm not optimistic that it's going to go down much farther. So we need all the fresh thinking that we can get. And if we can use bullying interventions, if we can use forgiveness, education with kids, any kind of psychological intervention that will reduce aggression, strength and impulse control, that's a big thing. American prisons are full of people with poor impulse control. Those things really start early. And that's our field. That's psychology. We're one of the only games in town when it comes to that, in my opinion. Well, Dr. Farley, thank you so much for joining us. It's been a wonderful pleasure. You're welcome. Thanks. Thanks for listening. If you would like more information on the
点，在最近几年，但不多。而且我不乐观地认为它会进一步下降。所以我们需要所有我们能得到的全新思维。如果我们能使用欺凌干预，如果我们能对孩子使用宽恕教育，任何能减少攻击性、加强冲动控制的心理干预，那都是一件大事。美国监狱里充满了冲动控制能力差的人。这些事情确实很早就开始了。而那是我们的领域。那是心理学。在我看来，当涉及到这一点时，我们是城里仅有的几个选择之一。嗯，法利博士，非常感谢您加入我们。这是一个非常愉快的经历。不客气。谢谢。感谢收听。如果您想了解更多关于
topics we discussed or if you would like to hear more episodes, please go to our website at speakingof psychology.org. With the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们讨论的主题的信息，或者如果您想收听更多剧集，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是美国心理学会的《心理学谈话》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。